When I first got my doctorate and it was called Dr. Poliakoff.
The only reason that I found the doctorate useful was to complain in
shops. If you telephoned and say, look you, this is not right.
If you've said it was Dr. Poliakoff, it produced an effect.
Now I have no idea whether so we'll produce an effect similar
effect, or whether people will just love.
Each year.
The UK government releases something called the new year's honest list.
This is a whole bunch of people receiving things like MBEs and CBEs and
OBS,
but of particular interest are the people who are receiving knighthoods and Dame
hoods. Now these can be all sorts of people.
They can be sports stars or celebrities,
or very often they might be people you've never heard of who have accomplished
things or done many years of service behind the scenes. But this year,
one of the people being recognized with a knighthood is our very own professor
Martin Poliakoff. Now, of course, first and foremost,
he's been recognized for his work over many years,
as a chemist at the university of Nottingham.
He's also been recognized for his work as an ambassador for science in recent
years as foreign secretary of the Royal society,
but of particular interest to me,
and perhaps you who watches these videos is another thing.
And it's written on this citation here,
that Martin has been recognized for his work in engaging the public with
chemistry, including through the periodic table of videos on YouTube.
Here it is in black and white. So anyway, I had a quick chat with, well,
I guess I should call him.
So Martin just a few days ago and asked him how he felt about the whole thing.
I already have a lower on the so-called commander of the order of the British
empire, which has a nice cross, which I have worn,
I think in total three or four times.
And once when I had to go down the street wearing this,
I buttoned that my anorak right at the top,
so that nobody should see this when I was going down the street, the knighthood,
as far as I remember,
and I've seen quite a lot of people wearing this is a sort of oval reddish
colored medallion, and now university. It is quite rare.
So Peter Mansfield, the Nobel prize,
when the discover or inventor of MRI,
our former vice chancellor,
Colin Campbell was knighted and I present vice chancellor.
So David Greenaway was knighted actually only a few months
ago.
Of course has got it for I've been awarded it because this is somebody who is a
top scientist and a top school.
Somebody who's been a fabulous communicator who has done so much through a
period table of videos to raise interest in, in the science.
But he's also part of a university community that he's grown up in.
He's been here 35 years and part of the university community is very proud of
what he's done. So this is a huge honor for the university,
as well as for Martin personally, and the ceremony.
Which I've never seen.
But I've heard about is that you are touched on the shoulder
by the queen or a member of the Royal family with a sword,
just like you see in pictures in medieval battlefields. And so on there,
I think the soul they use is rather lighter and less sharp.
Yes, indeed. There was a sword. It's not a myth. I was tapped on both shoulders.
The only thing that was missing was a rice, a David,
that that bit doesn't actually happen
beforehand. They,
they take them for briefing and there's a stool there and they take you through
kneeling down and so on. And to be honest, I thought, well,
what's the point of that, but it did it. And an official came up to me and said,
uh, so David, when, when you went down, you instinctively put your head down,
do not do that, keep your head up.
Otherwise you don't see what's happening and you'll miss the moment.
And it was wonderful advice. I kept my head up.
There was lovely eye contact there.
You can see the sword coming down that taps both shoulders. And, um,
then, uh, majesty had, uh,
a few words asked about my career as an economist and asked about work here at
university.
People in the UK are still really quite formal.
So if you're a professor you're called professor with your certain names.
So I'm called professor Poliakoff.
I prefer to people to use my first name and call me Martin.
So the tradition is that when somebody gets a knighthood,
they are called so in their Christian names. So in my case,
so Martin they're in full, I would be professors.
So Martin Poliakoff,
but nobody in their right mind would actually say that they might write it in
a formal documents. It is, I think for a combination of reasons,
I think it is partly through my role at the Royal society
as an ambassador for UK science,
but also it is for my role in chemistry,
partly my research in green and sustainable chemistry,
but also for my, um, efforts,
thanks to you,
the YouTube watches to promote chemistry through YouTube.
I think it may be the first time that YouTube has been mentioned when
somebody has got to knighthood. And so I feel really, quite proud about that.
And I also really want to thank you, YouTube viewers,
who've made this possible through your enthusiasm for chemistry. So in a way,
this is an honor that we can all share together.
I see this very much as an honor for the whole of the school of
chemistry at the university of Nottingham where I work.
So I see this as a reward, not only for myself,
but for my colleagues working this area and particularly for my research
team and my close colleagues who work with me in this team
and also for our technical staff who make all the equipment
that allows us to do the experiments.
I think my wife is fairly neutral about it. There,
it should be pointed out that there is rather unfortunate sex
discrimination that when a male is knighted,
his wife gets the courtesy title of
lady. But if a woman is made the Dame,
her husband's doesn't get anything.
I'm not sure what my wife's attitude to being called lady will
be. And that that's up to her, whether she uses the title or not fantastic.
Public recognition. And, um, you know,
that on there aren't many of them. Uh, and,
and I think the university having the opportunity to celebrate
an accolade like this for someone who's as loyal and as committed
and as straightforward as Martin is just a wonderful thing.
I think perhaps what I need to remember is that when I
was made a professor in 1990, 24 years ago,
my son sent me a birthday card.
It was announced fortuitously on my birthday.
And it said at the end PS, don't be pompous like other profs.
And I think this is really a very good attitude to have to all these
on those. I'm delighted to have it,
but I mustn't let it get the better of me.